what is up guys my name is silver i'm
from san jose california
la living shout out to you cat i know
you'd be repping sj
too so here's my dilemma
um a year ago i was definitely ghosted
by a 36 year old man
grown ass man right i'm 29.
um ghosting should be long gone we're
grown um
but given no explanation because i was
definitely blocked the whole nine yards
so i took that to heart figured i was
the issue got on my grind started
working out
eating right all that stuff prove it so
a whole year later dude wants to come
back now do i let him back in
part of me is kind of like oh part of me
is like [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] me up so um
should i let it ride
should i say [ __ ] you
help a girl out i need i need more
details on him yeah does he have that
stevie blue eyes dick if he does then
i'm going to say yes
i'd like to say no i am i would be
willing to bet yet another thousand
dollars that
as sure as i was that that asian girl
with the fakes
would get up and have a dick in balls if
silver
her name's silver latina girl named
silver
guarantee you know everybody knew that
guarantee you guarantee you if she
unbuttoned her shirt or took her shirt
off
100 tattoo on the tent yeah 100
it's a guaranteed slam dunk tattoo on
the tip tattoo on the tit
one thousand print maybe a row
maybe a name on there she so yeah says
miguel
across the top tit and she probably is
leaving out you're right she's leaving
out like a lot of info like
i didn't just ghost you either as a wife
and family or you [ __ ]
blew his house up you lit his car on
fire you did something crazy i blacked
out
and then you went home and made
empanadas and you forgot that you
[ __ ] beheaded his wife yeah she's
talking all soft and [ __ ]
yeah i got ghosts i got ghosted she
didn't just get ghosted though she got
blocked
she might have killed his cat yeah she
did something because she did something
she looks like she looks like a baddie
though because she's gorgeous gorgeous
girl
but this is dangerous beautiful and
crazy
latina that's latinas in a nutshell
that's latinos in a nutshell yeah spicy
yeah my daughter i worry about my
daughter man my daughter is so little
latina she my daughters and now as my
daughter's getting older i'm like
[ __ ] she looks exactly like her mom like
it's gonna be a problematic thing my
father was saying from my daughter's boy
he's like you better hope she looks like
you
you better hope that little girl looks
like you cause she looks like the kid's
mother you can have a problem
i'm like yeah i know and she's every day
i'm like just send my dad pictures
everybody's like wow that looks like
your [ __ ] girlfriend
he's like i can't help you i can't help
you i'm going to be dead soon i'm like
yeah dude i know it's going to be a
problem so i kind of hope
i'm ve that's why people like oh what do
you want a boy or girl i'm like i really
would like
of course just a healthy baby but i
don't know if i could deal
deal with two girls that are like minnie
me's two of my girlfriends
two smoke show a little bit yeah it's
gonna be an issue it's just gonna be an
issue
but what am i gonna do are your
daughters held five my daughter's five
my son's five wow they should hang out
imagine they get together
they're both half latina half white oh
that's wrong should we hang
look what you guys just did wow oh
that's true
when are the birthdays my daughter's
birthday is may 19th february 21st
so so your your boy just turned five
just turned five yeah mine's
yeah mine turned six in a couple of
months okay we should
well yes you can bring them up by the
crib absolutely all out here
everybody's out here dude i came with
the puerto ricans this sounds like an
arranged
marriage yeah it sounds like some [ __ ]
my parents would have done it's gonna be
great is she
active though because my son won't stop
is my daughter active yeah dude she was
up today at five o'clock in the morning
because we're still on new york times
she put the nutribullet on by herself
with nothing on top
yeah we were like we woke up and we were
like it was like she was like i have the
nutribullet going i'm like you literally
don't have anything on top of it she's
like well put something on it
this is fun little playdate
[Music]
is